Cheese predates written history.
Ancient Egyptians loved cheese so much that
depictions of the cheese-making process were
painted in tombs.
Homer’s Odyssey talks about how Cyclops
stored his cheese.
The Greeks and Romans used cheese as a delicious
currency.
During the Middle Ages, if there was cheese
on the dinner table, it meant the family was
of at least moderately wealth.
(For more on all this, see: A Brief History
of Cheese) While cheese has been around for
ages, many cheeses we eat today were invented
over the last five hundred years.
A few were even invented in the United States,
Monterey Jack cheese being one of them.
So, how did Monterey Jack get its unique name?
Before we get into that, we must go back about
three hundred years to the Spanish monasteries
of California.
In the 18th century, Spanish missionaries
began their takeover of California.
It was on July 16, 1769 when the first Catholic
mission was founded at present-day San Diego.
Over a sixty year period starting in 1769,
twenty one outposts were settled by Catholic
priests of the Franciscan order to spread
their beliefs among the local population.
The second one established, after San Diego,
was in today’s Monterey, California.
The Spanish missionaries’ very much desired
to be self-sufficient.
Although they didn’t quite achieve this
(some financial support came from the “Pious
Fund of Californias” established in 1697
by Spain; later, this would become the subject
of litigation between the US and Mexico),
they brought supplies, foodstuffs, seeds,
and livestock into California never before
seen in the Americas.
For example, grapes, apples, and figs were
grown for the first time in this part of the
world at this time.
These fruits had originated in Asia, but had
come over to Europe before this as a product
of trade.
Oranges (also originally from Asia) actually
were planted for the first time in North America
in the Gulf Coast and Caribbean regions about
150 years prior (approximately in the early
17th century) , but made their first appearance
on North America’s west coast due to Spanish
missionaries.
Livestock, like cattle, were also part of
the European colonization of America.
Arriving in the mid-17th century from Europe,
cattle were a huge food and supply source
(e.g. leather) for the settlers.
Of course, milk also came from these cows.
Any fresh milk that wasn’t used was preserved
by converting it into cheese.
In Monterey, the cheese they made was soft,
creamy, and light and became part of the Spanish
missionaries’ regular diet.
They called it, “Queso blanco pais,” or
“the country peasant white cheese.”
Hence, the Monterey part of the name “Monterey
Jack,” with the town itself named after
the viceroy of New Spain, Gaspar de Zúñiga
Acevedo y Fonseca, the 5th Count of Monterrey.
(The latter “Monterrey” ultimately derives
from the Galician “Monterrei,” essentially
meaning “mountain king.”)
But what about Jack?
Fast forward about seventy years, to 1841,
when a Scottish immigrant by the name of David
Jack arrived in New York.
He became a storekeeper with his two brothers,
who had already been in America.
It’s not clear exactly what their store
sold, but at some point they became army contractors
and hosted military personal, including one
Robert E. Lee.
Apparently unsatisfied with store life and
having heard about the great fortunes to be
made in the California Gold Rush, in 1848,
Jack made his way west.
Before he left, though, he bought $1,400 (about
$37,169 today) worth of revolvers in hopes
of selling them out west to “law-abiding
and lawless alike.”
He did exactly that and made a heady profit.
His gold speculating wasn’t as profitable,
though, and like so many others he moved to
San Francisco to try to make ends meet.
He became a customs agent and found his way
to Monterey on a business trip.
Jack fell in love with the central coast town
and officially moved there, but he struggled.
In fact, he went back to Scotland for a year
when his father passed away.
But he returned, determined to become a rich
member of the community.
In 1821, Mexico gained their independence
from Spain after an eleven year war to earn
the right.
In order to encourage expansion, the Mexican
government continued what the Spaniards had
started by issuing land grants, or ranchos,
to individuals.
These individuals were allowed to settle,
farm, and use the land however they sought
fit.
In 1846, only twenty five years after Mexico’s
independence, the US Army invaded the Mexican
territories of New Mexico and California and
the Mexican-American war began.
This wasn’t the first time the United States
had forcibly tried to take land from Mexico.
In 1845, America had “annexed” Texas.
Within twenty two months, the US had won the
war and their territorial expansion to the
Pacific Coast was complete.
The Treaty of Guadalupe Hidalgo allowed at
least somewhat of a conciliatory end to the
war.
The treaty called for several major concessions
on both sides.
Mexico was to cede California, New Mexico,
and the rest of Arizona to the US, plus it
recognized the US’s claim to Texas.
In return, the US would pay Mexico $15 million
(about $398M today), offer citizenship to
any Mexican living in those lands, and still
uphold the rancho system set up by the Mexican
government.
While these promises, in theory, were kept,
the United States government found a way around
that last provision.
US government-run commissions were set up
to determined who actually owned the ranchos.
The rancho owners were forced to provide documentation,
deeds, and records in order to prove that
this was their land.
Many could not do this due to the years that
had past since coming into ownership and the
lack of need for this type thing while Mexico
was still in charge.
Historians believe that this was a simple
US-controlled land grab, taking land by instituting
rules and regulations that were unfair to
rancho owners.
This is where we go back to Mr. David Jack.
In 1853, with the US still sorting out all
the land grants, the pueblo of Monterey attempted
to make its claim that the land belonged to
the town, not the US government.
They hired Delos Rodeyn Ashley as their lawyer.
He would later to go on to be California’s
treasure and a Nevada Congressmen.
He actually won their claim for them, but
demanded nearly a thousand dollars in fees.
The town was broke and was forced to auction
off its lands anyway to pay Ashley.
On February 9, 1859 at 5 pm, the auction commenced.
The sole bidders were Ashley and David Jack.
They purchased every single inch of land in
Monterey that day, nearly 30,000 acres, for
$1002.50.
Thus, Ashley got his money from the city,
and then some when he later turned over his
rights to the land to Jack.
It was not hard to believe that this was some
sort of set-up.
A suit concerning the auction and subsequent
purchase went all the way to the Supreme Court
and became known as “The Rape of Monterey.”
David Jack quickly profited on his purchase
through farming, grazing, and charging obscene
taxes on those who had built on it.
He was ruthless.
Jack acquired even more land and immediately
began foreclosing on properties.
He did this by posting foreclosure notices
on hard-to-find parts of individual properties
and in a different language- as in, if it
was a Mexican owner, the notices were in English.
If they were English speaking Americans, they
were in Spanish.
These lands hosted many types of business
that Jack now “owned,” including 14 different
dairies that were operated by Spanish and
Portuguese dairymen within the Monterey lands.
When they had excess milk, they preserved
it by turning it into cheese, the special
“Queso blanco pais,” or “the country
peasant white cheese,” much like their missionary
forefathers.
Well, since Jack co-owned these dairies, he
claimed this cheese as his own.
He slapped his name on it and called it “Jack’s
Cheese.”
Soon, the cheese began selling across California
and the west coast.
In order to identify where it came from, people
began calling it “Monterey Jack” cheese.
As you can imagine, David Jack was just fine
with this.
To this day, it’s still called Monterey
Jack cheese and derivatives, such as Colby-Jack
(a mixture of Colby and Monterey Jack cheese)
also exist, a homage to a ruthless, corrupt
California landowner who claimed an old cheese
recipe
as his own.